notice we hear a lot these days about
the push for diversity and inclusion in
the workplace but what exactly does that
look like well there's new research
showing that more diverse more Equitable
and inclusive leadership actually helps
organizations make better decisions in
fact nearly 90 percent of the time and
now there's a new road map to achieving
that author and executive coach Patrice
Gordon is just out with a new book it's
called reverse mentoring removing
barriers and building belonging in the
workplace she says that everybody
benefits When leaders and members of
underrepresented groups come together uh
tell stories share information and
Patrice joins us now Patrice good
morning good morning thank you very much
for being here uh the title reverse
mentoring I think it's almost
self-explanatory but not quite so uh
tell us what reverse mentoring is so
reverse mentoring actually started with
Jack Welsh and GA capital in the 90s he
recognized that the leaders in the
organization were so far removed from
what was actually happening with the
internet so the younger individuals and
generations that came in he got them to
Mentor the senior leaders so they had a
really good understanding of what is
this thing coming and how do we use it
and how do we make the most of it
so rather than older workers pairing off
with younger newer employees it's it's
the opposite absolutely opposite and
what I have done in in my research and
you know since the you know social
change that's happened it's really use
the difference that we have within
organizations to make sure that leaders
understand what it's like to be an
underrepresented individual so in the
work that I've done in the research I've
done I've extended that age to gender to
ethnicity to neurodiversity to veteran
status for example so those
underrepresented individuals within the
organization are really trying to make
sure they have a voice but you speak of
what you know because you did this your
boss you you you ended up mentoring your
boss but you said who is this harder for
is it harder for the mentor or the
mentee it depends and I was quite a
confident Mentor so I was quite
confident in my story but I definitely
think through my research and speaking
to lots of leaders the mentees
definitely have a hard time right as a
senior leader you are expected to have
all of the answers you're expected to
know the direction of the business
you're not necessarily expected to be
vulnerable and necessarily courageous in
the workplace and being a reverse Mentor
means that you need to put yourself in
that position of a novice and really
listen to the underrepresented so those
in position of leadership it's hard for
them to understand how to be vulnerable
absolutely because they're told not to
and they feel like it's a sign of
weakness in front of their employees
what advice do you give mentors
and tools Elementary
the senior leaders
yes the many ones is really um
understanding why you want to get
involved so you have power how do you
want to use it within the organization
are you willing to share your power and
if you are you need to put yourself in
that room and put yourself in that
vulnerable position to be able to do
that but you have to have buy-in from
the top you know after the death of
George Floyd many companies said listen
we need to change we need to be more
diverse we need to be more inclusive and
that seems to have petered off a bit
absolutely you say there's a difference
between diverse don't say diversity you
say say inclusion absolutely absolutely
so Verna Meyer she says you know
diversity has been invited to the party
but inclusion is being asked to dance ah
I like that I'm really in organizations
what we're trying to do is yeah we can
bring as many diverse people in as
possible but actually are they going to
enjoy working in the environment are you
going to get value from them because
they feel included and that's the key
that I'm trying to get to here but you
go you got to make sure it's spread
throughout the company it doesn't matter
if the leader says this is what we want
to do right it's not passed on to middle
management you can have these training
sessions and coaching sessions what
difference do they really make if
there's not buy-in from everybody
absolutely one of the key things I'm
really in invested in encouraging
companies to do is making sure that we
set some targets so as with financial
targets or sustainability targets you
know everyone's really clear that we can
get to Net Zero by 2050 but what about
diversity equity and inclusion targets I
think we need to get braver we need to
kind of put a stake in the ground and we
need to hold everyone to account and the
way that we do that is through hitting
them in the pocket you know making sure
that their their financial package is a
link to diversity equity and inclusion
God another way we do that is getting
the books thank you so much listen to
you all day I love you I'm on sale now I
love it